les dépenses publiques françaises vont
forcément considérablement augmenté au
delà même du mesures temporaires elles
ont atteint un niveau nettement
supérieur et le niveau d'avant crise
ralentissement de la croissance ou un
retour à la normale conjuguer un
maintien au niveau du déficit publics
entraînerait une hausse du ratio
d'endettement et ça pose un problème qui
est en pleine confiance des acteurs
économiques dans la capacité de la
france à honorer ses engagements passés
donc moi je propose de faire ces
économies je propose même de mettre une
règle d'or dans la constitution
budgétaires et fiscales pour permettre
de retrouver l'équilibré je le dis hein
la dette c'est des impôts différés ça
veut dire qu'on transfère sur nos
enfants la charge de nos dépenses
d'aujourd'hui